flames engulfed homes near london
shortly after the uk's record
temperature was smashed the london fire
brigade declared a major incident
with blazes breaking out across the
capital and across the uk
the london fire brigade in particular is
dealing with a number of large-scale
incidents spread right across the
capital
and assisting partners in the home
counties as well so all of the emergency
services both in london and our home
counties are under significant pressure
at the moment
fire ravaged trees along this road in
kent
the danger though was not just from the
flames
health warnings were issued to protect
vulnerable groups such as the elderly
and young children at risk from
dehydration heat exhaustion and heat
stroke
but with temperatures likely to peak
more frequently emergency doctor cavian
cooler sabanathan says it is the poor
who will bear the brunt of a hotter
briton
this is a public health emergency
so this climate crisis that we're
talking about isn't this abstract thing
in the future if you live in poor
quality housing you know the housing
stock that we have in the uk it's too
cold in the winter it's too hot in the
summer
it's those who live in poor quality
housing working class and racialized
communities that are most likely to
suffer
overheating within their houses these
are the people at the sharp end of the
climate crisis the economic crisis and
least responsible for those two things
as well
in the london district of birmingzi 72
year old francis stout was trying to
keep cool on her balcony a respite from
the heat inside her council flat
well you can feel it now aren't you
and regardless of the bit of sun being
there we don't get that sun very often
but what you've got now is the heat that
we get every time
it's absolutely degrading around here if
they're not to stand it'd be a blessing
elsewhere youngsters enjoyed the weather
[Music]
lighter side of a worrying picture for a
country that was once wet and cold
the record temperatures in the uk have
brought with them a host of problems
from wildfires to pressures on the
transport system and on the health of a
population not used to these conditions
with climate scientists saying that the
worst is yet to come the country may
have to learn to adapt as quickly as
possible
paul reese al jazeera london